you are celebrating the Warriors win  tonight you're a big fan is there a fan  experience that you haven't had as a  Warriors fan that you've always wanted  to have well yeah you know I made it on  the on the screen on the little video  but the one thing that I've always kind  of wanted to do is go on the court and  shoot those cool t-shirt cannons now you  know you know you see the ones that  those cute little cheerleaders wield so  well yeah and and I was told maybe I  might be able to shoot some t-shirts  into daughter Stan is going to shoot  some teachers  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  find your son badly defeated  [Applause]  hey thanks for watching please subscribe  to my youtube channel so they will stop  making me shoot these videos please